the government has announced a three
percent pay rise for nhs staff
in england ministers have accepted the
recommendations of the nhs independent
pay review body
the government says this will mean an
additional thousand pounds a year
for the average nurse let's bring in our
chief political correspondent
john craig uh good evening john so i
mean the unions
were asking for quite a lot more how
will this be received
well probably not too well because it's
not this is for
nhs staff in england uh and in scotland
uh they have already been awarded four
percent
three percent in england and also in
scotland the pay rise has been backdated
to december
whereas in england this pay rise is
being backdated just till
april um the announcement from the
government comes just hours after helen
wakeley the health minister
told mps they were still considering the
recommendations
from the pay review body so anyway we
now have the full statement from the
government
in which they say they've accepted the
recommendations of the nhs
independent pay review bodies in full
uh for this year now some months ago the
government was saying could only afford
one percent so they've obviously moved
from there um
the three percent pay rise for nhs staff
in england includes
nurses paramedics consultants dentists
and salaried
gps and for the average nurse as you've
said a thousand a year
many porters and cleaners will receive
around 540 pounds
and the health secretary sajid javid who
of course has
tested positive and is isolating says
nhs staff are rightly receiving a pay
rise this year
despite the wider public sector pay
pause
in recognition of their extraordinary
efforts we ask the independent pay
review bodies for their recommendations
and i'm pleased to accept them in full
with a three percent pay rise for all
staff
in scope from doctors and nurses uh to
uh
paramedics and porters had the
government not accepted this
recommendation in full
there would have been an almighty row
given all the praise the clapping
for nhs staff during the pandemics so
i guess there will probably be relief in
whitehall
that the pay review body did recommend
three percent
not as much as the unions want it
obviously but the government will be
able to say
we have accepted their recommendations
in full uh we haven't stuck to what we
were saying before about one percent
but the unions are bound to say
this is a a poor offer uh compared with
scotland
just to recap three percent in england
back dated to april scotland have
already announced
four percent backdated to last december
so
a better deal north of the border